hey everyone welcome to metaphysical
milkshake the show where we go deep we
get weird and we search for the meaning
of life along the way i'm your host reza
aslan and i'm rayne wilson the co-host
co-host meaning with the most
meaning that i am above you clearly in
the in the competition over podcasting i
am the host and you're the co-host i i
guess i that was not my what i meant by
co-host
i said co-host with the most
meaning that i am the premier podcaster
between the two of us
and um you know what i think that um
we need to have a podcast off
a podcast
i'll pop hot off you right now
i'll pot off you right through this
computer if i need to that sounds just
that sounds gross
[Music]
here's the deal we're so competitive
aren't we very competitive people
you and i are competitive certainly um
but
we're in competitive industries aren't
we i mean you're an actor like you're
literally competing for a role yes
actors compete for roles yeah but you're
a writer you compete for the top spot on
the new york times bestseller list
that's right and i hate everybody else
ahead of me on that list above you and
you watch those little charts and isn't
that what we do
it is it's all about like who's best
who's number one who can who can deliver
i audition for a role and then i i look
in deadline hollywood and i see who got
it and i'm like
i hate that guy right i mean i have to
be honest with you like i am like i mean
i'm competitive in weird ways i'm i'm
competitive not in sports you know okay
but i'm i have this like maybe it's my
persian heritage where i i have like
this feeling of guilt about the fact
that i'm competitive so i try i pretend
that i'm not competitive i'm always like
no no no no after you after you but deep
down inside i'm like you son of a [ __ ]
but the persians call that tauroff tarot
yeah it's a very very complicated thing
in what ways are you competitive mostly
competitive well like for instance
every time
a sort of you know fairly young brown
person
succeeds in media i'm like [ __ ] that guy
i'm gonna admit something right now i'm
gonna i'm gonna actually confess this is
good this is good you're making yourself
like quite vulnerable here i i love
hassan minaj he's a friend of mine i
want him to succeed but every time he
succeeds i'm like why is that [ __ ]
succeeding and not me
i'm brown
yeah i guess i'm the same way with with
poorly middle-aged bearded character
actors like nick offerman i love him
we're good we've been good friends for
almost 20 years but he gets a role i'm
like damn you offer men no but this
culture of competition it's like it's
internalized right we're all like this
everybody is like this yes our whole
culture is based on this everything is
based on competition and on contest and
this is why we need to dig into this
life's big question which is what reza
are we biologically wired
to compete with each other i mean isn't
that what darwin taught us isn't that
what the whole point of evolution is
right winners and losers and the winners
survive and the losers become dust we
need to explore this idea um i have a
buddy who is gonna be on the show uh dr
michael karlberg he is an author he's a
professor at western washington
university he wrote uh two books beyond
the culture of contest and a very highly
regarded tedx talk on the same topic and
his new book that just came out which i
haven't read yet because it's very fancy
there's too many big words it's called
constructing social reality and it
builds on the work of his first book by
examining relativism cynicism and
materialism that the culture of contest
gives rise to and how this undermines
our struggles to conduct more peaceful
and just social
forms
basically just uh so many isms and i
guess his point is that
maybe we're not actually
hardwired
for survival of the fittest maybe that's
not maybe it's not contest
and competition maybe it's cooperation
that's like the
salvation of the human race
maybe there's more that makes us tick
than contest and competition
maybe there is a smattering of
cooperation
mutualism
could it be the survival of the kindest
and not the survival of the fittest
let's find out
michael karlberg thank you so much for
joining us you're welcome it's great to
be with you i loved your ted talk uh and
this whole thing about the culture of
contest man it was so fascinating to me
could you
just uh for our listeners i mean i
already get it i'm i'm smart enough to
understand it but i mean for you know
our dumber um listeners uh what ex
exactly is the culture of contest
well really really you want to start
this whole conversation by insulting our
listeners okay great that's great
that's just great isn't that for our
stupid listeners
please explain
the thesis of your book and your life's
work just for the dumb ones
the smart ones already know everything
about you michael all four dumb ones who
are listening for the dumb ones exactly
we need the introduction thank you dr
karlberg please
uh well you know in our society we
organize almost every social institution
around competitive principles
right our partisan political system our
legal adversary system
our capitalist economy our educational
systems most forms of recreation and
leisure
and uh
that's the culture of contest this this
assumption that
human nature is fundamentally
competitive and aggressive and we should
therefore try to harness all that
selfish energy by organizing most of
what we do
around a competitive model but aren't we
naturally
that the competitive
isn't that true i mean you see it
everywhere it kind of feels like it it's
it's on the news it's like you mentioned
sports and um it just it feels like
humans are really naturally competitive
well i mean it's no question we're
capable of competition you know we're
wired for both competition and
cooperation but in our society
we cultivate and value uh competition in
ways that actually in many ways
exaggerate its influence in our behavior
um in fact if you if you look back you
know studies of hunter-gatherer society
show actually they're
far less competitive than modern society
so
you know if you think about like what is
the sort of natural state of human
nature
uh it's actually far more cooperative
than what we see in our society today
where we actively cultivate competition
in virtually every sphere of our lives
but i guess like
i mean i feel like i remember in high
school being told that that was the
entire point of the human condition that
the
that the you know nature of evolution
going all the way back to darwin's
theories was precisely that it's the
survival of the fittest that we're
competing with each other about who gets
the boar or you know who can climb the
tree and get the nuts or whatever i mean
isn't that hard you said it was
hardwired into our brains but it's more
than that right it's part of our
evolutionary process
well so you just said two things that
often get conflated survival of the
fittest and competition and the
assumption most people make is that
the most competitive are you know the
more fit to survive
but actually there's really been a whole
recent movement in like evolutionary
biology recently which has shown that
mutualism
the ability to cooperate both within and
across species
actually increases fitness and is as
fundamental if not more fundamental to
evolutionary processes than competition
so we've been misunderstanding darwin is
that
what you're saying well
uh yeah but actually darwin is not the
one that actually equated survival of
the fittest strictly with competition
this is
uh overlay on darwin's thinking darwin
talked about survival of the fittest
absolutely but he didn't equate it with
competition in any sort of simple way
that it has sort of come to be
understood in popular
popular understanding here's a fun fact
that um i'm gonna throw out there this
is not something that i know i'm not
smart enough to know this it's in my
research document to be perfectly honest
but it was herbert spencer who summed up
darwin's thinking and used the phrase
uh survival of the fittest actually and
secondary fun fact he's the inventor of
the paper clip that son of a [ __ ]
so he's probably a billionaire who also
coined the phrase survival of the
fittest and how did he survive he
invented a paperclip
well in fact here's the here's a funny
thing about herbert spencer is that what
it seems to me like what he was trying
to do was take darwin's
evolutionary theory and kind of wrap it
into
a social theory for societies right
because that's that's really what
survival of the fittest starts to mean
it's not just about
you know uh
the evolutionary process that allows you
to pass on traits to
your children that will make them more
likely to survive the
harsh reality of neanderthal life or
paleolithic life and it's much more
about like
well you know white people are just
smarter than non-white people and maybe
civilization
needs to root out some of the the people
who aren't as strong uh either like
physically or or emotionally or whatever
the case may be i mean i guess that's
that's what's really fascinating about
what you're saying is that if we're
questioning the very notion of
competition as an evolutionary process
well then we're also questioning
everything that came out of that right
like political darwinism and social
darwinism and economic darwinism
essentially civilization as we've known
it for the last 200 years
yeah absolutely i mean so so what
happened you know darwin and a number of
other people
you know of his era really helped sort
of articulate some of the underlying
mechanisms of evolution but those then
got grafted onto a whole sort of social
political ideology
as you refer to social darwinism that
we've since
used to justify implicitly or explicitly
how we structure society how we
structure all these institutions
and
it's actually not justified by a sort of
sober look at evolution
and you know beyond that one can also
add the concern that
even if evolutionary dynamics are
fundamentally competitive in this
context of like the struggle for
survival in a context of scarce
resources
well humanity has solved the problem of
scarce resources we're no longer in the
struggle for survival our challenge is
not is not actually
not enough resources our our struggle
really is is has more to do with the
just and equitable distribution of
resources today
so the whole logic of the struggle for
survival in a context of scarce
resources doesn't even apply to humanity
there's another aspect to darwin's work
um i'm not sure if he used this phrase
or if other people used this phrase
about darwin but i've heard this this
idea of survival of the kindest this is
kind of a big thing now like survival of
the kindness is how a species climbs up
the evolutionary ladder so
does that work in terms of animals and
does that work in terms of human
societies yeah i mean what you're
referring to broadly is mutualism right
it's this idea that when
species cooperate
they both do better so you know
most
trees and plants
rely on fungi in the soil to help fix
nitrogen and feed them to the roots and
in exchange
those fungi get other benefits nutrients
that they draw from the trees that's
mutualism it's a cooperative
relationship
on some level
the entire plant kingdom and the entire
animal kingdom exists in a mutualistic
relationship with the exchange of oxygen
and carbon dioxide in our atmosphere
or you look in the human body you know
there's
people
biologists estimate now that for every
human cell in our body
there are about 10
foreign creatures foreign organisms so
that's so we're only actually about one
in ten you know
our own human self
some people are starting to describe the
human body not as a body but as an
ecosystem the human ecosystem
that's foreigners living inside of you
foreign
that's mutualism i'm more concerned
about aliens living inside of me yeah
think about it if there are micro aliens
living inside each of us that's a whole
other podcast isn't it yeah
certainly i get what you're saying
michael that you know um
even if
it is true
that like way early in our evolution
uh it was about competition and survival
of the fittest and all that and that's
that's questionable and even sounds like
even darvin was not
uh necessarily promoting that view it
sounds like it was much more this uh
this jerk off uh
um and his [ __ ] paper clips um but
i
even if that were true what you're
saying is okay but we're not in that
world anymore right we're just in a
different world and so
it doesn't work anymore to compete um
and and uh you know the sort of winner
take all mentality that the only way
that we're gonna survive now is if we
cooperate with each other
yeah absolutely i mean our our success
as a species both reproductively and
technologically
we've transformed the conditions of our
own existence i mean we literally don't
live in the world we evolved in our
bodies initially evolved in so we've
changed the conditions in which our
species now exists and
the problem is we haven't adapted to
these new conditions so we're still
sort of uh you know living with
inherited cultural practices and
patterns and values and codes that may
have worked reasonably well when there
were very few of us on this planet but
they have become an existential threat
now that there are seven and a half
billion of us with you know technologies
that that
increase our impact and our danger to
one another a thousand fold
this podcast is sponsored by better help
is there something interfering with your
happiness or something preventing you
from achieving your goals look we all
have these issues you know i mean we're
in the midst of a pandemic a slowly
dying democracy the world is on fire
we're punching people in airplanes if
you're not
somewhat anxious about the world right
now you're probably not paying attention
and if you are paying attention you
could probably use someone to talk to
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist you can start
communicating in under 48 hours this is
not a crisis line it's not self-help it
is professional therapy people done
securely online i highly recommend it
there's a broad range of expertise
available which may not be locally
available and this service is available
for clients worldwide i know we have a
lot of listeners you can log into your
account anytime and send a message to
your therapist as well you'll get timely
and thoughtful responses you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
and also you don't have to sit in those
uncomfortable therapy waiting rooms
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches and so you can
change your therapist if you need to
it's more affordable than traditional
offline therapy and there is financial
aid better help it really truly wants
you in these very dire circumstances to
start living a happier life today visit
their website there's tons of
testimonials there that are posted daily
that's right just go to betterhelp.com
milkshake that's better h-e-l-p
and join the over 2 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using betterhelp that they are
recruiting additional therapists in all
50 states this is a special offer for
metaphysical milkshake listeners you can
get 10
off your entire first month of therapy
at betterhelp.com
milkshake take care of yourselves
kickoff 2022 friends with a better
checking account with no monthly fees
chime is an award-winning app and debit
card with no overdraft fees foreign
transaction fees monthly fees or service
fees with over 60 000 fee free
in-network atms at many many locations
like most walgreens 7-eleven cvs you can
access your money when you need it where
you need it you can also send money to
anyone even if they aren't on chime fee
free for you and no cash out fees for
them reza this is this is changing
everything this chime you know
first we had the banks with the checks
and then all of a sudden you could wire
money and then you can do this and then
others then there was paypal and now
there's you know venmo and cash app and
crypto and
this is the next generation it's uh
chime it's it's a whole new way to
encounter banking it's easier and fee
free and very consumer friendly yeah i
mean look have you ever tried pulling
money out of like a 7-eleven atm machine
it's like 30 bucks
i just wanted a donut i gotta get my
slurpee on bro so make your first good
decision of the new year you can join
over 10 million people using chime and
sign up only takes about two minutes and
it doesn't affect your credit score get
started at chime dot com slash milkshake
that's chime c-h-i-m-e dot com slash
milkshake and now the actor will tell
you the fast part go banking services
provided by a debit card issued by the
bank corp bank or stride bank n a
members fdic get fee free transactions
and any money pass atm and a 711
location and at any all point or visa
plus alliance atm otherwise out of
network atm withdrawal fees may apply
sometimes pay anyone instant transfers
can be delayed the recipient must use a
valid debit card or bhi member to claim
funds
maybe back in the day cavemen got ahead
by being better at clubbing other
cavemen
and that promoted them and then we
misread darwinism
um in terms of competition and survival
of the fittest is what we need to
survive and here we are at this point
where we're our own worst enemy right
and there needs to be a major
psychological
shift
uh if we're to survive so this culture
of contest or competition is not just
like oh hey here's a good idea wouldn't
it be nice to get along kumbaya utopia
hippie it's more like hey if we are
going to survive as a species we have to
shift our entire way of doing things
yeah that's what i'm saying and
ironically that's quite consistent with
what darwin said you know these the
process of natural selection which is
what darwin fundamentally was focused on
right uh it has to do with how
well-suited a species is to its
environment to the conditions in which
it lives right and if those conditions
change it drives
change in species uh and that's the
situation we found ourselves in our
conditions have changed now it's not
gonna
drive change in our in our sort of
physical you know makeup as a species
it's what it's going to drive change in
is our cultural uh habits our social
patterns the way we organize society the
way we raise young people the values we
impart all of those sorts of things
but fundamentally
yeah we have to adapt now
and the longer we drag our feet the
longer we resist the the more human
suffering we're going to see it's a
function of the environment we live in
now yeah i mean look you've totally
convinced me uh i just feel like it's
such a
such a tall order you know um like i get
it of course we live in a globalized
society and of course we're
um you know in a situation in which you
know we're not all
fighting over the the same resources
like we're not all trying to hunt the
same exact animal it reminds me actually
of of this quote by eo wilson that i
really liked he says within groups
selfish individuals beat altruistic
individuals
but
groups of altruists beat groups of
selfish individuals and that makes sense
but if you think of the globalized
society as one big group
and you know most of us ninety percent
of us have decided okay we're all gonna
have a a you know a culture of of uh
kindness right that it's survival of the
kindness like like uh rain was saying
that it's uh mutualism cooperation all
those wonderful words but if ten percent
of that group is like no [ __ ] that uh
it's all mine
you know what i'm saying like the whole
and we're screwed we really are true
we need seven and a half billion people
to get on board with this idea don't we
not just
7.3 billion people because those couple
hundred million people could then be
ruling as our overlords by the way i'm
pretty sure we just described america
didn't we i think we just
basically but you know what i'm saying
right michael i mean this is a tall
order oh yeah this is not going to be
easy at all i mean but the reality is we
don't have a lot of choice and there are
awful lot of people i would say
majorities of people today who are
working in various ways towards the kind
of change we're talking about so really
i think it's an increasingly small
minority
that's
you know clinging to patterns
of the past often that
uh
you know accrued a certain privileges to
certain groups of people at the expense
of others
um but i mean what i see working with
young people for instance today you know
at the university is more and more young
people are
seeing beyond that
they're they recognize that this the
game's up so to speak like we can't
continue to play by the rules we've been
playing now speaking of the rules that
we're playing in what about economics
because isn't the whole economic system
built on the same premise it's
capitalism is competition you know um in
order to make money you have to win out
you know
uh
blu-ray beat betamax or vhs beat betamax
and it won and it won the marketing
battle and it won the consumer battle
and it won out and that's how we
economically move forward so
are you saying that there needs to be
for some people right like
the free market economy is like
practically scripture yeah there's
there's the bible there's the
constitution and there's adam smith yeah
and adam smith would be um appalled at
the way the current economy is
structured because adam smith was a mor
was a moral philosopher
and we have an economy today that is is
completely unmoored from
from moral commitments i think it's
helpful in this regard to actually
uh to to draw a distinction between
capitalism and markets you know market
economies
i have no trouble with i think we need
market economies
capitalism is just describe a mark
what's a market economy i mean you know
the relatively free exchange of goods
and services right between people who
are
uh innovating to produce them and people
who need them there you know we could
get into more technical detail but
but the the problem is capitalism is
only one way to organize a market
economy
all market economy there's no such thing
as a perfectly free market economy a
perfectly free market economy means you
know i kill you if i don't like what you
know what i bought from you that that's
a completely unrestrained market economy
no rules contracts can't be enforced
there's no such thing as currency like
that's
you know a truly unregulated free market
there's no such thing all markets are
regulated this question of how
capitalism is one way of organizing a
market and it's a way that privileges
the accumulation of wealth and capital
in the hands of fewer and fewer people
so capitalism clearly has become
problematic it's a sort of hyper
competitive
uh
social darwinistic way of organizing
markets we need to disentangle
capitalism from markets and think about
more rational sustainable equitable ways
of organizing markets so it's not a
choice between capitalism and like
centrally planned you know communist
economies the choices between capitalism
and
more just and sustainable market you
know relationships i don't know rain
this sounds suspiciously like socialism
to me it sounds a little like socialism
and it sounds a little utopian and again
if you have a market economy like this
like a just and moral market economy
you still have that small percentage of
people that if they want to [ __ ]
everyone over with their
with their monopoly that they gain
then
they're going to win
how do you answer the the charge that
what you're talking about is just
utopian
hippie dippy falderal
well i mean again the situation you're
describing is the one we live in right
now it's just a description of reality
and my argument is
that uh it's simply no longer viable
like it's collapsing around itself
uh it's
more and more people are actually uh
paying the cost you know the pandemic
has brought this out clearly in this
country and around the world it's the
sort of gross inequities
and at some point
uh people don't stand for it anymore
the the challenge is you know how do
they work for change you know one is you
you bring out the pitchforks or the guns
and
you know you have a sort of perpetual
state of instability and conflict and
violence and war which much of the world
is continues to be engulfed in partly as
a result of his gross inequities
the alternative which is what i advocate
is uh you know
populations communities can begin
constructing alternative systems
alternative economic arrangements
alternative systems of governance even
for you know regulating those
arrangements
and so there's a path forward which is
actually to construct new models and
attract people
to those models because they're more
just and sustainable if if the people
who
eventually are sort of benefiting so
much from let's say this sort of
distorted and unjust you know
arrangements of the present day if they
don't got if they don't want to get on
with the new model eventually they'll
find themselves
with no one left to play with so to
speak i mean
you can build
new models uh independently of whether
or not you know people want to exploit
the old the old models the old games are
you aren't you talking about kind of a
commune like a communal system like a
system within a system like of all of
the people of some like progressive area
like the the berkshires in massachusetts
said we're going to start our own
currency and have our own markets and
our own trade and whatever is going on
in the united states we're gonna have a
more just and equitable system and we'll
put food aside for the poor and we'll
have volunteerism and etc etc isn't
isn't that what you're talking about
uh not communes because what call means
you know the commune model is to
actually try to withdraw from society
and build something somewhere else sort
of in isolation that's impossible you
know our interdependence today
ultimately makes that impossible what
i'm talking about is actually building
up new systems new models right within
the sort of shell of the old a lot of
other people have written about this i
mean you know fundamentally this is what
gandhi was talking about he talked about
a constructive program which meant
building up new ways of of organizing
economic life social life political life
right within the shell of this sort of
oppressive british raj at the time
that's what he was trying to sort of you
know
develop now
uh
he didn't advance as far as he'd hoped
with that particular model and a lot of
his like civil disobedience was
you know
an effort to sort of throw off the
british raj
in the hopes that he could continue to
advance that constructive work
but that's the fundamental idea is
we build right where we are new systems
as they attract more people
that's how change how radical
transformative change eventually comes
about okay so
talk us through what this world
this kind of post-competition
world could conceivably look like
whether it's utopian or whatever
you know i mean
we if we progressively phase out
this kind of
uh competition mindset right this
culture of contests that you talk about
um
what is it what does it look like what
does the world look like that way then
well i don't want to presumptuous you
know be presumptuous and offer some sort
of grand design with all sorts of
detailed architecture of the new world
there in a lot of ways my argument is we
have to learn our way forward we don't
know all the details but we can apply
certain principles
and begin to learn our way forward
a few things already i think that are
becoming reasonably clear
for instance just starting the
educational domain which we're all
familiar with there's all sorts of
evidence and it grows every year that
the sort of competitive grade-based
model where you reward and punish
students you know based on their sort of
competition against one another
actually undermines the motivation to
learn
there are a lot of experience
experiments happening in education right
now
with people trying to figure out what
does education look like beyond
competition
so we need to learn our way forward we
don't know exactly what the you know
future world model you know the model of
education the perfect model is but some
general principles are emerging and
learning processes are under play
we see similar you know process of
experimentation and learning in the
economic sphere for instance the
emergence of of benefit corporations b
corporations recently you know
it provides a whole new way of actually
structuring a publicly traded company
that moves it beyond this sort of narrow
almost pathological short-term profit
motive at the expense of all other
values
that's a that's a um
an experiment worth sort of following
and building along with other sort of
cooperative economic ventures and you
know cooperative economics is not new
it's been around for
quite a long time
we need to pay a lot more attention to
it
uh ideally create you know more
opportunities for that sort of a
learning path so we can look in every
domain of sort of social life and say
where are the sort of cutting-edge
innovative uh
experiments being done that are trying
to
move beyond the culture of contest what
can we learn how do we build on that
learning
you know i had a light bulb moment
during the last election
and it was during a democratic debate
and
kamala harris
got in a like a a one-two whammy punch
on joe biden and it was front page news
for all of like eight days of just like
oh wow she skewered him she got him oh
he wasn't expecting that oh wow yummy
and her she went up in the polls look at
that she went from
11 to 27 because she got these zingers
in and i thought what the [ __ ] are we
doing what are we doing why is a measure
of someone's leadership capability uh
equated with their ability to get in a
zinger a pre-planned zinger by the way
at a debate this is ridiculous why why
don't we look at people's
accomplishments at their plans
at their
at their way of cooperating with one
another and not their way with competing
with one another so when i saw that
happen i was just like you know what i
am done with this whole system this
whole democratic system of uh raising uh
oh they raised 170 million dollars in
their war chest and then they won in
this debate and they got zingers in
against the other person and they're
saturating the airwaves and they're
going to win and they're a winner and
the other person's a loser like i'm just
like i'm just so done with this whole
system
the cbd work well 90 of doctors said
their patients have used cbd to treat a
health condition i mean i guess if nine
out of 10 patients use cbd that does
speak volumes about how safe and
effective it can be i have definitely
used cbd to help me sleep sometimes when
i'm like in my super anxious mode and up
and awake at three in the morning with
my head spinning like
that's so interesting like i just got
this package from cbdistillery.com
and there was this whole thing about how
you can use this to get a good night's
sleep i haven't done it yet you're
telling me
it works yeah it does work and there's
no like hangover druggy kind of feeling
at all it's just kind of blissy
so let me tell you about cbd
distillery.com with over 2 million
customers cb distillery get it cb
distillery
is the source i trust when patients tell
their doctors they use cbd for help with
their health health conditions what are
some of those conditions reza well we
talked about sleep apparently 90 of cb
distillery customers said they sleep
better with cbd including one rain
wilson if nagging discomfort is a
problem 80 percent of customers said cbd
helps with discomfort after physical
activity
what about nagging neighbors no
i don't know if it helps with that well
in general if you're looking for some
peace and calm these days then i guess
you would be wise to explore cbd if you
haven't discovered the power of cbd
you're missing out go to
cbdistillery.com
where you order online with no
prescription required and enter
milkshake for 20 off again enter
milkshake for 20 off at cbdistillery.com
that's
cbdistillery.com not available in idaho
iowa and south dakota
politics is another arena that this uh
culture of contest works in right uh so
what does democracy 2.0 look like what
is how do we govern ourselves how do we
govern 300 million people uh without
kind of this
rabid
uh competition
yeah so that's a really important
question and i think here again we've
like confused the idea of democracy with
the idea of competition so even the idea
of elections right the assumption we
make in modern societies is that
democratic elections have to be
competitive and how else could they be
well the reality is they don't have to
be there are other models there are
people learning about those models so
you know let me just take you through a
sort of thought experiment
imagine if you you know were starting a
country and you created a constitution
and everyone you know every adult
citizen had the right to vote every
adult citizen was eligible to be voted
for even if they didn't want to serve
and whoever got the most vote votes was
tapped on the shoulder and said we know
you didn't want to do this but you were
just elected to serve and you're going
to have to give up your other priorities
to serve the community now
imagine
a constitution organized around those
principles
it's actually more democratic than what
we're used to today because when you
vote
you can vote for anyone you think is
qualified who has the who has integrity
and honesty and a service ethic and
demonstrated the capacity to you know to
to serve the public so you have true
freedom of of of choice when you vote
well and whoever's running by the way
are are entering rolling up their
sleeves and entering knee deep into this
culture of contest because they are
they're competitive and they want to win
and they want power because isn't that
ultimately what this is all about is
like the quest for power and so then
you're opening up the playing field to
those that don't want power you know and
then you could we could elect someone
like bill gates maybe that's a terrible
example i know
he's a satanic
baby you just want microchips in all of
us that's what it is planting microchips
in all of humanity but you know someone
who's a successful businessman who is
also a philanthropist and has a lot of
big ideas and works well with others but
isn't necessarily seeking power in the
same way that a politician might be yeah
in fact i heard it said once that
if you think you can be or if you think
you should be president
that is disqualifying because if that
you know what i mean like if that's who
you think you are
then you know you've got issues that
will you know necessarily not make you a
very good person
megalomania narcissism
in a politician interesting so you take
the competition out of the democratic
election and what you're left with is
you don't have parties you don't have
the corrupting influence of money you
don't have ego and ambition as
corrupting influences
and you have true freedom of choice
that sounds like something a little more
democracy 2.0 to me and there are
already
groups in the world experimenting with
these principles learn you know proving
the start give providing the proof of
concept around this sort of electoral
model so again
we need to learn we need to generate
knowledge about how to do these how to
do these things on scale but but the
general principles are there and
learning processes are already advancing
around these things so going back to
what rain was saying so what
what's the obstacle then i get the
societal obstacles in the way of this
kind of idea but
i feel like the obstacles to the to the
kind of society that you are talking
about
it's more than societal it's more than
institutional it's more than you know
even economic it's sort of deep seated
it's within us as individuals right that
there's something about the way that
you're talking about uh cooperation and
kindness over competition and you know
winning
that
rubs people the wrong way you know that
it's not just because they've been told
all their lives ever since grade school
that it's all about competition and
survival etc
it's that
there's something
about what you're saying that almost
kind of takes away my individual agency
right it's like you're asking me to be
part of a group and to think in terms of
what's best for the group instead of be
an individual and think what's best for
me i mean
there are a lot of obstacles in the way
of the world that you're
envisioning but that seems to me the
biggest one but what you're describing
raza is is a frequent used kind of
talking point on the political right
which is like hey as soon as you take
away my individual liberty in any way
shape or form you're going to
quash kind of individual initiative and
if i'm beholden to the needs of the
group i'm not going to be able to thrive
and i'm not going to be able to go in a
basement in silicon valley and be steve
jobs and start apple computer even
though i have no plans of doing that or
any
you know ability to do so i might right
that's it's it's that whole view that
gets you know
uh
poor people to support policies that
actually help rich people because you
know one day they might be rich yeah you
know i mean
when we when we begin to sort of move
beyond the culture of contest it
actually opens up opportunities for
individual agency and creativity and
developing our creative potentials
because
again you know the the challenge of the
world we live in today is
so many social groups
actually never have the opportunities to
do that because of the inequitable
distribution of resources and various
sort of injustices we live with today
in fact most of humanity never has the
opportunity to realize their sort of
inner creative potential
that's a function of the world we live
in today of the culture of the social
darwinism we live in today right so
it's only if we move beyond that that we
actually begin to liberate our sort of
true individual
uh sort of latent capacities and
creative talents and those sorts of
things but
of course it takes some social
imagination to recognize that especially
if you're born in a country like the
united states where we've been
indoctrinated into this
very sort of narrow competitive
individualistic you know world view yeah
i mean i hear what you're saying that
you know in the world that we live in
now a world of plenty you know
cooperation is the the proper path
forward
but
don't we constantly hear about how
we're running out of resources and you
know
water is scarce and the planet is dying
and and there's going to be you know all
these food deserts everywhere and the
zombie apocalypse is right around the
corner i feel like
now more than ever it's about like
what's mine and
you know keeping
the zombies at bay isn't it
well it definitely feels that way i
think to a lot of people who are shut
out of the global economy today right
who don't have access to the sort of
bounties and the privileges that are
available
uh but again that's a that's a function
of um
how unjust and inequitable
you know these arrangements are
there's nothing you know there's no food
shortage on this planet we have enough
food to feed
you know everyone alive today and
several billion more
the problem is the distribution of food
and access to food and healthy food
right so you know
one could also you know add the layer
that this sort of dysfunctional
governance that we live with today
that's
not even able to sort of i mean we
subsidize
the least healthy food choices in the
united states today
and
and
and make it very difficult to find
healthy food
that's not because it's more difficult
to grow healthy food it has to do with
how the system's been raked to subsidize
you know sugar and corn and
cheap calories
which can be grown by large
agro-industrial sort of complexes that
you know that concentrate large amounts
of wealth
and put a lot of farmers out of work in
the process you know small family
farmers and such so really these are
questions
about
about uh how poorly or how well
the world's resources
are organized not about whether we've
you know are somehow in some locked in
some struggle for over scarce resources
today
we have the technology and the know-how
to take care of
everybody on this planet
health food
uh all these things and we're only
getting better at that
the question is about distribution and
access so but if we're not competing
michael like what pushes us to do our
best you know what drives us towards
excellence what motivates us forward if
we're not competing yeah so i mean again
this is i think another one of those
myths that people only strive for
excellence when they're competing with
others and when they're driven by
self-interest because
it helps to sort of unpack how we even
understand the word competition
people today talk about competition what
they actually mean is
self-interest
combined with striving for excellence
equals
winners and losers
plus progress for the winners right in a
sense that's kind of the you know the
formula the implicit understanding but
if you actually take the self-interest
out of that equation and substitute it
with with altruistic motives with with
motives that about you know contributing
to the betterment of the world one lives
in
that's it turns out a very powerful
motivator for excellence as well for
excellence for creativity for innovation
so
uh
humans are motivated by by things other
than self-interest it turns out we're
motivated by
love and and compassion for others by by
actually just the intrinsic reward of
being creative think about all those
artists out there who give their life to
creativity and never never even you know
earn a living
clearly they're not being motivated by
self-interest they're being remote
motivated by the intrinsic reward of
creative excellence
and the same is true in many other
fields so if we disentangle
self-interest from the pursuit of
excellence what we find is there are
actually equally if not more powerful
motivations at play
that humans can tap into i feel like
you've completely convinced uh rain and
me
and like i'm a different person over
these after these 45 minutes of talking
to you uh but what about everybody else
like what
what's the incentive for
you know everyone else to to
accept this idea of a culture of
cooperation instead of contest
well i think we're sort of staring down
the barrel of two of the biggest
incentives in you know the history of
humanity right now one is uh this
pandemic that we're living through which
i think clearly teaches us that we are
totally interdependent on this planet
and that ultimately we're not going to
solve these sorts of things certainly
not like prevent them in the future or
learn how to manage them well in the
future
without
you know levels of cooperation we've
never
previously you know developed
and global warming is the other one it's
it's it's an existential threat it's
planetary it again shows our sort of
total interdependence
and it's something that no country can
solve by itself no group can solve by
itself certainly no individuals can
solve it has to be a global you know
cooperative enterprise on a scale that
that again we've never been able to
achieve so
so we live in this moment of history
where
the stakes have never been higher the
incentive's never greater
and the consequences of sort of failing
to adapt
at some point will become sort of
unimaginable and we really won't have a
choice
so michael what what do we do so you
play you're going to be the therapist
now the listener is the patient
you know change has to start on a small
level and it starts in our thinking
process right on an individual level uh
before it can move into a family group
and then a larger group in a
neighborhood in a community and what not
like what would you want people to leave
this with to say how do they how do they
shift their thinking around this concept
and make
active tangible
change in their lives moving forward
yeah i mean i guess one thing one way to
start is just to be willing to question
some of the deepest assumptions that the
modern world is built on and realize
there's social constructs like the world
doesn't need to be this way so
willingness to question deep assumptions
and widely held sort of views and then a
willingness to sort of
uh do the internal work you know
overcoming the ego and and and those
competitive impulses that we do have
they are part of us but they're not the
only part of us and we can actually
develop
you know our cooperative altruistic
potentials with effort
uh
so
doing that inner work but of course one
can't do that in isolation like that
most of that inner work actually
occurs in relation with others and in
service with others and in practicing
these you know qualities and virtues and
interdependencies with others so
seeking out groups who are able and
willing to
learn how to create new patterns of
social relationships and
and ultimately you know new
institutional forms and
and practices
where do you find these groups like on
meetup.org you want to meet down at the
uh
at the farmer's market on on sunday
morning and um
do a trash cleanup
well i think you can actually find once
you begin to realize what it is you
might be looking for it's not so hard to
find people doing these in various
domains i mean just follow the smell of
patchouli
yeah
yeah there are people involved in my you
know relatively small city i live in
with their cooperative economic ventures
happening there's educational systems
being developed that aren't based on the
principle of competition they're
organizations who are trying to learn
different sort of models of leadership
and decision making
so i mean all of that is available in a
town of 100 000 people that i live in
that i can seek out
um religious communities are often
not exclusively i mean there's a lot
that happens under the name of religion
today but many religious communities
have developed
uh patterns and and systems of of
cooperation and mutualism and not just
internally but there's a growing you
know sort of interfaith movement in
which people are realizing we need to
learn how to cooperate with people who
have other faith beliefs so
i think there's a lot of opportunity if
we really begin to look but we have to
expand our imagination and and make the
effort we have to certainly get up off
the couch and look for for who's doing
this kind of work around us that we can
join and also it seems like we have to
begin with the self right i mean start
here start with yourself
uh
you know
figure out how to change the way that
you think about
how you interact with the world and with
society you know stop
thinking of
survival as a zero-sum game and you know
think about cooperation and not
necessarily
uh competition and winning know that you
know
for you to win it doesn't take someone
else to lose like these they're if i
feel like there are stuff that's what
you could do exactly what you just said
is just really resonated with me reza
like
for you to succeed doesn't mean someone
else needs to lose and we're just in
that kind of dichotomy polarization of
one up one down you know one upsmanship
literally and um and and i think you're
absolutely right like to go on a daily
basis of um
hey am i engaging in a process like that
in at my work or at my school or at my
church or in my family dynamic where
someone needs to win and someone needs
to lose yeah like just change yourself
first you know it seems pretty basic but
it's a shift in consciousness and then
hopefully you know
society will will follow okay lightning
round michael this is a a little part of
the show where we just ask you a bunch
of different kinds of questions and then
you answer them you know the first thing
that comes to your mind
you ready here we go now try what makes
you laugh out loud
question like that
uh what is one thing you hate
abusive authority describe your soul in
10 words or less contemplative focused
uh
wanting to leave the world a better
place than i found it when was the last
time you ugly cried i can't remember
it's been a long time men don't cry what
is what is one thing you know for sure
the earth is round you sure about that
really you haven't you haven't gone on
the rabbit hole of the youtube videos
flat earth videos
okay and finally what is your life's big
question my life's big question
uh what am i gonna do when i grow up
i got some bad news for you man i think
you found it yeah yeah i think you're
doing it
yeah yeah stick with it i think you're
in the right world it's working for you
it's working for you thank you i think
you're in the right ballpark so michael
out of all of this discussion this has
been really illuminating but in your
opinion and just you know just between
us three right now like who was the
better
podcaster mia reza i mean yeah that's
not i mean not part of this competition
thing like we've rain and i have changed
we are different people now we have
operations on a higher level it doesn't
matter to us one wit but i'm better
right i might be on my questions my
interjections i was more articulate come
on if we were just going by who asked
the best questions i'm not saying it's
important it's clearly not important
what about bringing levity levity is
important i think i might have to bring
chad ebenrod in as a judge to help him
choose this one oh
[ __ ] him
he wins everything with
our podcast is so much better than him
and we're gonna overtake them in the
ratings on the podcast ratings there can
be only one michael carlberg thank you
so much this was so fascinating it was
like it was actually you know
life-changing very few podcasts
are life-changing this one was
life-changing uh i agree i think these i
think these ideas are profound um and
i'm so excited to get you on the show
and uh thank you so much for being our
guest
thank you for having me it's been fun
milkshakers as you well know when you
rate and review us on apple podcasts and
you ask one of your life big questions
and we like the question you get to come
on our show and ask us in person
and in fact we have someone here who is
doing just that uh ryan ryan how are you
pretty good how's it going i'm well man
uh where are you calling from i'm in
indianapolis indiana but i'm from
california
nice nice all right all right brian i
understand you've listened to every
single one of our episodes that is
phenomenal wow what a feat
yep
i don't believe them you you do you
believe them i don't believe them there
was one episode where reza wasn't on it
i skipped that one oh that's a good call
wow
that is a good call actually you're
talking about the david chowi episode
which is actually my favorite episode
that we've done the best episode we did
was david cho with no res up what uh
what's your question man hit us make us
think so my question for you guys is
why do you or why do humans believe in
god
not does god exist i think that's a
different question that i don't find as
interesting but why do
why do we believe or why do most people
believe why did most people believe in
god it's true most people do believe i'm
going to hand this to you because you
wrote a book about god and basically can
you talk about this book that i have
right here oh human history new york
times bestseller published by random
house available at all find bookstores
everywhere and online all right
no this look
rayna's right this is a question uh that
i that i'm very fascinated we're both
fascinated in i just happen to have
written a book about it why do we
believe in god again that's ryan was
right like this question of like does
god exist does god not exist that's a
stupid question like that's not a
you know there's no proof either way
like anyone who can who who tells you
that they can prove that god exists or
doesn't exist is trying to sell you
something you can just ignore that
person
and also i would say that
we should be clear about what we mean by
god right because it's weird this word
that we all kind of hold in common and
we all have this idea that we all mean
the same thing when we say god but and
the truth is that we don't we don't mean
the same thing when we say god but if if
what you're talking about ryan is like
why do people believe in some like
higher power outside of themselves you
know some kind of
sort of supernatural creative force out
there that may or may not you know
control our destinies people are divided
about that
that is a universal belief
it exists amongst all peoples in all
cultures wow throughout all
of human history that's deep when you
think about it there's not like some
tribe that's just completely had never
even thought about some kind of great
spirit or higher power nope
in fact it is a belief that predates our
species it's a belief that predates
homo sapiens it's a belief that we have
found material evidence for
amongst neanderthals
with certainty amongst neanderthals with
far less certainty among older uh
species of humans and in fact
there's a lot of sort of cognitive
psychology out there
that indicates that we may possibly
be born with this belief
that
the belief in a concept of a of a like a
you know a spiritual
entity or a reality beyond us
uh
is something that we're born with
uh so then to ryan's question
why
i wrote an entire book about this and
and i can tell you the answer is we have
no [ __ ] clue well i can i can say
some i can add something to that
so i spent some i spent a couple years
as an atheist
uh just to try it on kind of like how
was it like a jaunty cap you know it was
it was interesting because i needed to
kind of like get away from my roots as a
baha'i and kind of find my own way in
the world so in that sense it was really
interesting but
here's here's what happened it just
didn't make any sense to me
it just and i'm not talking about like
does god exist or not but like
the universe without some kind of like
greater unifying power force energy
uh will
uh
you name it like without that in it it
just it didn't make any sense it's like
why why is there just stuff there's just
stuff without meaning and there's just
more stuff and all of a sudden there was
no stuff and then there's a bunch of
stuff and the stuff transmorphs and
transmogrifies and then stuff gets gets
consciousness
that it that it just didn't compute
right what do you think ryan
i think it's funny that you said that
because my follow-up question for you
guys was
what does the world look like what does
the universe look like without a god
because for me you said you were you
tried on being an atheist i am an
atheist and that i don't believe in a
god
so this
the answer to that my second question
what does the world look like without a
god or the universe this is it like i'm
living that
that's just how it is how's it how does
it feel for to get over there for me
it's fine that's why i think this
question's so interesting because for
every person is different right for you
it's obviously very important your
religion your spirituality your belief
in some higher power it shapes who you
are and how you view the world and
without it you felt lost for me it was
the opposite i don't i did i just never
really connected
with that
with religion or with that belief but
i'm still living my life doing
i'm still happy i still have a wife and
a kids and i treat people with respect
and i have a moral compass and i do all
those things that religion
uh teaches you
i just don't i just never had that
connection so it always interested me to
hear why people believe or not
yeah and you know what i'm glad you said
that because i want to make sure that
people understand
we're not saying that
you're like a lesser person if you don't
believe in this idea of a higher power
or whatever i am it may very well be
true
i'm kidding
it may very well be true
that we are born with this belief again
there may be very complicated cognitive
reasons why we're why we're born with it
there's all this theory now that maybe
it is an accidental byproduct of some
other
you know evolutionary development that
happened early in in our brains and that
as a byproduct of that like as an echo
of that was this kind of universal
belief in
quote-unquote
god and that is perfectly natural you
know in the same way that like we don't
have tails anymore right or
uh
what's what's that or is it the
gallbladder that we don't really need
what is that is that is that the organ
so many things we don't need right that
that maybe that's what it is that
because a thing that we needed that's
why we're all born with it that's why
it's universal that's why it's part of
our evolution but we don't need it
anymore the one thing that i do think
that is very important that i just want
to say
is that
in fact gallup has done
a decade or more
uh of of surveys showing
that at least in america i don't know
what it's like in the rest of the world
but at least in america by far
the most moral community
are atheists
that in almost every category
violence against non-combatants uh you
know uh responsibilities towards society
uh you know civil responsibility like in
almost every category
the most moral community in the united
states is the atheist community far more
moral than christians muslims
jews come in second believe it or not
but you know any other any other faith
community so there's nothing wrong with
you if you don't believe in god you're a
perfectly fine person
the question though that i find
fascinating is
if we're all born with this ability if
it is
embedded in our brains and that's what
that's what the science is telling us
right now that maybe there's a reason
for it i don't know maybe not i don't
know what the reason is but maybe it's
because
part of being human
is
the longing
for
transcendence the longing for
a connection with something that's
beyond us even if we don't really
understand it yet
yeah i think uh
i think god makes sense i think it makes
things easier i think it answers a lot
of questions that are otherwise
impossible to answer
and it makes
the briefness of life
a little easier to swallow i mean if you
believe that
this is just one beginning and you're
gonna live on forever with your loved
ones as opposed to just what i believe
which is i live for these 70 years and
then i am dead and that's it that that's
a little tougher to swallow i think yeah
it can make things a little more
complicated because if there is an all
higher consciousness what does this all
higher creative force
in the universe uh
want from us
uh and expect of us
and responsibility and why were we put
here toward what end and kind of
figuring that out you know on a on a
daily basis and a yearly basis is hugely
stressed can be very challenging can be
very challenging indeed but ryan these
are wonderful questions i'm so glad
uh that we were also able to have the
civil conversation because so so many
these youtube debates are like
you know
oh atheists are going to hell and
theists are uh are idiots that are
non-scientifically based and um
uh
and the fact is
we need all of us to be working together
to make the world a better place and uh
great leadership has happened in making
the world a better place
by the atheists god bless you atheists
i mean we're still going to talk [ __ ]
about you when you hang out yeah but but
yeah but this was nice as you should
um this was awesome thank you guys
wow wow reza that was mind-blowing i
feel like i'm a different person i feel
like i'm a different person and i feel
like this needs to be kind of a
different podcast now doesn't it i i
couldn't agree with you more and in fact
why don't you go ahead and just uh you
know take us out because no no no no why
don't you please no no you i i ca i
honestly insist you are clearly the
superior podcaster can i be of service
to you how can i let the great reza
aslan shine why don't we just like end
this thing together
that's that's exactly what michael would
want us to do right okay good okay good
excellent
so michael
carl um
milkshake well we'll check out the video
releases check out the video on
you know i'm you know what maybe this
cooperation thing isn't really
working for us what about i know every
other word
got it
so
subscribe rate and review metaphysical
milkshake on apple podcast or wherever
you
like
to
listen
hey
cooperation
and by the way you can also check out
the video releases each week on youtube
you just don't need to get that answered
you just had to get the last word in
it's always you always have to get the
last word in
we're screwed as a society we are
screwed
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samazadeh yazd harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubel
cast media is the production and
distribution partner original music by
jeff tang
[Music]
look some people are more competitive
than others uh you know i'm married to a
woman who was
a student body president all four years
of high school in all four years of
college
what so
that that that tells you a little bit
about my household
wow yeah
jessica doesn't lose stuff
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you